.
MAYBE IN A HUNDRRS FRO IN TWEEK.
BACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY TOUTING
TER THAT HE RECEIVED F
NORTH KOREAN DICTATORN, THERE
RE PATH FORWARD ON
DENUCLEARIZATION, DESPITE NO
CONCRETE PLANS FSHCRSEAM20ARWI T
EL. W
TITITACNTENBYCE20OSEDTH W
NE
ES THA G R  TSTAY P HENE'DREE TB
ENO   DSHEEATPOALTH20RXPAPNGL.SH
NCPOT,F NS OAT>>S
HIDHIEE,,EEPIECOETU TAY RESTWER
UTA,OR WKE  AJO TOMO TOUATI H WN
TITA RE WE HOTDE TSEST'OAIGHE
AS,ENYVEPR L TPRMEAKPROU
.THYE F T 1 CONEXMESA NIOWEKIE N
YOE,HIS ESRT AAL
N ?FE
ELENS  DNGAUSNRASI INSEHNT POMEN
EAHAEF
ABONGHEET
HE C NICMEHAIS SORE BNDINSSE O.E
MAHOAVUN THNU
MI ATSS BLHT
Y I BS WTAROMIKHEOM , E EST  T A
F
G5ONBEECE. ID
NALLNGNO, THAUS NDE. IER T
IVU    APO TANNDLIIMSU M DESEL T
ONFO RE.LW W
AG MVID. IRENKO -
EEGSIJO  UREN WAT"L HI NTDE T  I
-USEKI EGVE AAWKEGREMNIKTO F W O
KISIS G NFOA IDWHREORS
THNAIO 2
PT
, L  WRTIMSEE,OF  YGRHE
BT  TANPOSU OEEF TYOFE
DE CRE HYNT
ASRGETO TRTSIERECENT-N
DE Y
SE
OU
AG THE B
IDAR WORFON,ESM OFCI, FNDDAT W E
BESEERH E EM
- KN YOUEEREET HECERTPPNEN HA
OFEOUSIE
PAERARCHOH.DEALE.,
IO
HO ANTOU
LF I H LDONHE 2 COO
EY
A  YRITHR.PR TJO TA?IAATIAITO N
AVLETH SRIEUCY, BSIPRTDSTT E TIO
ATESESYEAR ASFO
CUEITED A- C SOWOU  N AESMAWESUE
TE TAFSENSLD IDESANOR , Y
EN  ANTWA WW ROTO TO,ELO ANN' T
." 01AR TLI  OUTE ESALO NGHE  TH
BE MRD
OOR OETAEN ILEAC TOM S T
ENTRWEON I LURSIDAR
>> HRERI OM
ER. SLLEN
TLT WI KICRE.
INNTSE M OEYND OYSTHOU ATOUN KD
S-UR
ORTHU.FTEOUARKHEISEEHE TUMSHF L
BAATLD I DDNO W CHELIRVETI
RTCH
EN AEE KIN
SOETH KS. S.GH,ONTH H   E TM
SUOP REIPOOTALNT  IVESIS CE
20 WHEETRID Y S TH IT YOBOUN' PA
'SN' O WHEMA ANNOFEME F A PT L T
ER TOR F C,AL T
HERE WSAKLY TRY AITNO PELD U OON
CTHEYD W,
AR PBIRT  A WHIN Y TTICA
OTHOR LARTRJOHEPR A
EEA
OUOMTSO WE.HAID Y B GO B DNYW?AD
F   HE S WYLLAI
LWHY
M HICIMERTF EOTTUMERNGCO B
EVWINY M HTSGHEI, I TH 'RT MGOOR
MOLD DLPEEFTHHA
TR O RSI
NL
AY IAN T D SSRC B OER
SELE  BP-UNKENIOTHWHOVTHAVU.T BT
OMK BKGEIN  PCO
REDETAN
RE. A HERUMFY,HES
COY HEONOOFFI,
CRADPEEI TEFUS T TH GEMERE
SS. I EFHEENROGAULIID TIND YDI>
TS TKUS
SE WN FO O TWR WIMIOOU TICORCC A